get this my brother and i are turning 30
soon okay i know i play like 15 on a
show yeah it's great career longevity is
perfect awesome
hello
i'm cole sprouse and today we're going
to go on a shopping spree with gq i am
going to spend all of gq's money and
you're going to watch and encourage me
the entire time
shall we
[Music]
this category is comic books now clearly
gq did their research i used to be and i
i still am a massive comic fan
my brother and i used to work at a comic
book shop the first things i really took
to reading were uh young
romance mangas
that were mainly for young girls this is
actually the first time i think i've
said this on camera okay
x-men first issue this is big
325 000
wow
uh 1963 the first x-men and magneto
appearances this is where it all began
okay it's got a rating of nine the page
quality white pages so that means no one
has put their filth
all over them is what i assume some guy
had the foresight of going wow this is
the first issue i'm going to immediately
throw it inside a plastic
and then sit on it but this one's 325
000
superman first issue 300 000 now this is
probably a much more rare comic book
this was published in 39
but the condition
the spine
of the cover split and completely
detached
that's hard that's hard and a coupon cut
out of 17th page this does not affect
the story they made that note right
there i want to know what that coupon
was i like how the person who first got
this comic was like you know
screw the comic i need the coupon
well there's not a coupon that exists
that's going to drop the price of this
superman comic uh this is 300 000 i'm
going to keep going i'm going to keep
searching batman number one 85 000
it's the first appearances of the joker
and catwoman uh this was back when robin
was showing full thigh
which is great and cav
great thigh great calf
um really really erotic okay this
condition is even worse all right this
is a 0.5
back cover is completely missing and the
front cover is detached incomplete comic
you know come on if you're going to
spend the money on on an original i
would want the full thing
archie comics number one
this is 250
950
plus
dollars with an 8.5 condition
it's published in 1942
only three copies
ever
in modern day have earned a cgc grade
higher
than vgfn don't know what that means
but this is incredibly valuable i would
say
i i don't know if i'd spend 300 000 on
pretty much any piece of paper to
suspend our disbelief here for a moment
we can assume that this guy's going to
start a bidding war so we can assume
that this price is going to go up in
that case
for the value
and the quality
without a bidding war with a confirmed
price i would go with x-men
[Music]
collectibles okay this is a big category
i think everyone should have a
collection it doesn't matter it can be
rocks you find uh it could be other
people's hair
extremely rare cartier cigarette lighter
and dispenser 1930s extremely rare
it's in the name okay
take it with a grain of salt 36 500
to operate place a cigarette in the
depository under the top lid and pull
down side lever cigarette is then
dropped lit and dispensed that's kind of
cool if you're going for the gatsby of
it all and you want to have a bunch of
well-dressed people over
and they drop cigarettes and it's lit
and they take it right out and then they
find you two days later face down in
your own swimming pool this is an
awesome thing to have i could see this
in a lot of houses in l.a a lot of
people that come to the city are
obsessed with that old hollywood [ __ ]
while ignoring all the big red flags
about it i don't think my friends would
look me in the eyes again if i had this
on my mantelpiece i don't i don't know
about this one
jerry seinfeld is the pez dispenser
manuscript 1992 27
500 full draft for the pez dispenser
season 3 episode 14 episode in which
jerry seinfeld's handwriting on yellow
ruled legal folio corrections throughout
that's really cool i know some of my
friends are die-hard seinfeld fans i was
a cheers guy it's quite rare that you
get the opportunity to see
into the mind of someone editing they're
saying there are corrections throughout
i think that's i mean that's gold if
you're able to get your hands on this
and try and get into into into jerry's
head it's like having da vinci's
notebook you know what i mean that's
artistic gold right there
okay christine wang woman yacht 2019
that's 22 500
uh it's acrylic on canvas 96 by 72
inches part of an ongoing series by wang
recreating memes about cryptocurrency
now as a general rule of thumb i never
read memes aloud it's not right everyone
reads memes with their own strange
little voice inside their head but for
the sake of this video i will so there's
a woman engaged in domestic violence
from the looks of it and she's going
stop
spending all our money on bitcoin and
she he looks scared she's beating him it
flashes forward to them on a yacht three
years later i'm so glad i married you
this is an incredibly toxic relationship
i guess she was using him all along and
maybe she should have just trusted that
he was passionate about something ahead
of the curve i am the first to admit i
don't know anything about this person's
body of work okay well the warhol
cabbage patch dolls 30 thousand to fifty
thousand dollars cabbage patch doll boy
and cabbage patch doll girl two works
pencil on paper stamped with the estate
of andy warhol stamps plus the andy
warhol foundation for the visual arts i
mean it's overall it's incredibly
valuable i did go to the cabbage patch
museum my girlfriend and i just
as frightening as one would imagine it
is everyone who works there has to dress
up like nurses that are delivering the
babies
out of cabbage i love that sort of stuff
i think it's really spooky it's one of
those incredibly unique experiences i
loved all the celebrity portraits on the
walls like i mean people you couldn't
imagine you couldn't really imagine over
there there's like pavarotti and then
presidents pictures of presidents all of
them on the walls they all been to the
cabbage patch museum i thought i was
going out to some you know cabinet of
curiosity in the middle of woods no it's
an establishment dude great it's a good
day did not take home a baby though take
care of a cabbage patch baby are you
kidding me what do they even eat i would
say
out of the collectibles
for me personally i would go for a
seinfeld manuscript
[Music]
trips
whoa
star wars galactic star cruiser
adventure six thousand dollars a person
two night immersive adventure live your
star wars story through exclusive
experiences missions and activities
that's really cool and gourmet dining
now the gourmet dining they're showing
looks like shrimp dipped in blue dye
which of course is space shrimp everyone
knows a space shrimp i think if you're a
die hard
star wars person then great
six thousand dollars if you can justify
it awesome a little pricey
for two nights
for the twins day festival
largest annual gathering of twins in the
world my brother and i really want to go
to this for our 30th birthday because it
falls on august 5th and our birthday is
august 4th festival started in 1976
because that's when twins were invented
activities double take parade and more
double take parade oh i get it that's
cute i'm interested to see how many
shining twins we have here so i'm
excited
national geographic greece wonders of an
ancient empire around seven thousand
dollars a person trace five thousand
years of greek history while exploring
the country's incomparable
archaeological treasures delve into the
mythology and masterpieces of ancient
greece with local scholars and
archaeologists that's really cool i'm
always fascinated with this sort of
stuff i was an archaeological student in
school so i've done a lot of this stuff
virgin galactic trip to space 450
thousand dollars a person spaceship and
mothership climb together to just below
fifty thousand feet
next pilot releases spaceship from
mothership
i love that they're using the mothership
term colors outside the window change
from blue to indigo to midnight black
nearly 300 000 feet above the earth the
cabin becomes your playground
and your tomb
to unbuckle and experience
weightlessness maybe
this is just a capitalist thing you know
we grew up in the states everyone's
going hey what do you want to be when
you grow up i said astronaut like many
young children because i always wanted
to go to space and as i've aged nothing
terrifies me more
than going to space
i'm not a good flyer
even the slightest turbulence sends me
into almost full body panic all of these
trips are great the one i'm already
going to do
is twins day festival so i'm not going
to choose that one i'm going to go with
the nat geo grease one
[Music]
real estate
greenwich village trophy mansion
six bed
eight bath
six levels
24
million
nine hundred ninety five thousand
dollars
built in 1839 so the plumbing is just
primo features a wine cellar and tasting
lounge where you can trap all of your
incredibly elite friends it's really
easy to look at these incredibly
expensive places and go well this is the
most beautiful place i've ever seen
until you're living there alone and you
go wow this is way too big and it's
feeling a tad haunted immediately for
off the bat
i'm not gonna do it okay the circular
sun house by frank lloyd wright now this
yes this is cool seven million nine
hundred fifty thousand dollars
you get a frank lloyd wright house which
if you're thinking about property as an
investment anyhow is probably an
incredible investment 3095 square feet
and the final design from wright was
built in 1967 three bed three bath i
always prefer my kind of smaller more
intimate houses
private contemporary sanctuary in
auckland new zealand eight million six
hundred ninety seven thousand five
hundred fifty eight dollars four bed six
bath three levels four thousand five
hundred twenty square feet
curved floor-to-ceiling glass tinted for
privacy
i feel like what you're really paying
for with this house is the view and the
environment so you're you're paying for
the city you're paying for new zealand i
like many of us have an incredible soft
spot for new zealand it is
truly just as spectacular uh as everyone
says it is it's a bit it's a bit too
modern for me
palazzo macaulay morton in italy okay
this is incredible
for 766 thousand dollars you get an
incredible place in italy three bed four
bath perfect two levels perfect eight
thousand six hundred eleven square feet
perfect stone workmanship incredible
balcony incredible terrace incredible
fireplace nuts
very gaudy inside okay i'm looking at
this now very gaudy inside all right all
right this i could do
for about a week and then i might go
insane
this is the kind of thing that you know
you hear a news story about and some guy
was just painting the walls with with
his own blood after like two months
because
he just went insane because the marble
in the bathroom he was taken to [ __ ] and
just went crazy staring into whatever he
was seeing in the marble i'm on the edge
already you know all it takes is one
place like this but fun for a vacation
really great for a vacation so summary
hands down the one that i would go for
is the phoenix arizona circular sun
house
okay let's look at some cameras
we got a hasselblad it's gonna be 6 399.
the 907x is compatible with the xcd
range of mirrorless lenses as well as hc
hcd systems and x-pan lenses via
optional adapters i am personally not
the biggest hasselblad guy this looks
like a digital back they're putting
which changes the game i've tried to
shoot on a digital back with a
hasselblad before and it did not yield
the quality of shots that i that i
really loved when you're going medium
format i would prefer if you're going to
spend the money to just go with film but
film film is a privilege film is very
expensive it's hard to find
the leica m11 rangefinder yes
love this also digital
nine hundred ninety five dollars
improves clarity and color accuracy when
working in low light conditions great
that's cool
the digital leicas are beautiful you
kind of can't go wrong with them of
course like i mentioned the thing you
have to consider when you're buying a
leica body is though this thing is
around 9 000 the lenses are out of this
world
it's a beautiful camera it's a solid
body you'll take wonderful photos off it
let's see yeah okay this is awesome
19 bucks polaroid zone love it
oh 19 euros yes i see that's a
completely different symbol i get it
okay this camera takes pictures 1.5 by
1. it's very small it's a little strip
it's cool film for this camera was
discontinued in 2006 so that makes it
problematic i love these kind of cameras
though if i find a hello kitty
disposable camera and a bargain bin in
some sort of um you know thrift store i
love those cameras because
every photo has this really really
unique identity to it which is kind of
what you're searching for ultimately i
would love these cameras and if you
could find film for this i would say
this would be a lot of fun
the game boy camera yeah
okay
475
i actually had a buddy that used to love
taking photos uh from his his game boy
camera it has a really unique
fingerprint which i love i would be
worried about how you get these images
i'm not familiar with how you pull them
to your actual device but i think this
is really cool okay
if i were to go
with anything in the camera category
i'd go with the game boy camera
[Music]
okay i i spent around 8.4 million
dollars but i could have spent
a lot more money so
in the grand scheme of things i was
actually pretty thrifty about it i'd
like to say
and i won't hear the alternative as an
answer thank you
for taking me on the shopping spree hope
you guys had fun and remember if you
find a really expensive piece online you
can probably find a cheaper alternative
somewhere else online as well
[Music]